[Music]
all right well today um we're going to
talk about
making a wordle app uh or an app like
wordle i should say
basically you type in a word that's five
letters and um and then
you
you know you hit enter you click a
button
and
and then it checks how many of the
letters
in that word are correct or uh are
present in the target word and then it
prints that out and then you need to
enter in another word and you just keep
going so that's a that's a pretty simple
that's a pretty simple thing
so for our wordle app our overall
strategy is going to be to first work on
the logic of the application
and get that all working and then once
that's done
we will make it look pretty using some
css and a little bit of javascript and
we'll do that in a later video in this
series what you're seeing here is the
actual
shiny wordle app at the end
and this does take a little bit of css
and javascript work but it can be done
so um
you know the way that i like to get
started with
uh with problems like this is to just
start with something really really basic
and then build it up so there's some
there's some problems where that's not
really the appropriate approach
um
but for something like this
i think that's the way to go so first
we'll work on the logic and then
um and then later on we can work on
making it look nice but the first thing
is to to get you know the game
logic working properly
all right so
um got our studio started and i also
already have my word list here
so i won't go into the depth about how
how to do that but um
it's there so um let's start with by
making a simple shiny app library shiny
um the ui
is we'll start with a fluid page
and i'm just going to put in a text
input for now
right so that's that's that's the thing
that how people interact with it is they
type in text and tune input text input
collect guess
and we actually we won't put a label on
it
and um
all right
there's that and server
input output
and
actually sorry the first thing i'll do
is not just have people type in input
but i'll just have it print out what
they typed so
we'll do a um
verbatim text output
let's load up shiny so we can get some
autocomplete
text output um
call it result
oh and also a little tip
we'll do placeholder equals true
okay so then that will just make it so
the text output is always visible
otherwise when there's no content in it
it's not it's not visible so that um
it's sort of it can be a little bit
surprising if it
uh
sort of appears out of nowhere or
disappears when there's no content there
okay so uh let's see let's do output
result and
we're for right now we're just going to
have it echo the text that the user
types in
under text
uh we'll do
input
input dollar guess
and then
shiny app
ui server
okay so
now our studio recognizes an app
recognizes it's an app and um just for
convenience since there's a little thing
i want it to show up in the little
viewer panel down here
so oh i already have it set up that way
and i'll click run app
and here's my app hello
it shows hello there all right so that's
that's the very start of our our wordle
app
so right now it's a little bit
you know every time i type anything it's
going to show it down here but i only
really want wanted to do something with
the input
um when i say i'm ready so i'm gonna and
i'm gonna do that by adding in a button
so say action button and we'll say call
it go
and we'll label it go
and
now we have this render text here
um there's actually a number of ways we
can we can do this but uh
i'll show you i'll show you one of the
sort of relatively new ways of doing it
i can add it i can use bind event so
um if you're familiar with like event
reactive or
observe event
you can have those things
run only when a particular you know when
some other reactive thing happens so
like when a button is clicked and so you
can actually use bind event with
reactives and observers but you can also
use it with these render functions so i
can say bind event
input dollar go
okay so
it will only run
it will only sort of it'll only
update this and uh or execute this and
update
the result text
when the go button is pressed
and i still haven't figured out the best
way to do indentation for this it looks
a little funny here
and i'm using the new r4.1 style pipe
here since i'm running that version of r
and i'll save it and reload so
i can say hello and nothing should
happen until i press go
say goodbye
again nothing happens i'll press go and
now and it's just replacing the content
of this uh this text output right now so
that's um so now is a good time to start
doing something
with that
okay so let's see um one thing that
let's see how do we do this so in in
wordle
all of your guesses are limited to
uh words that are five characters
and and actually on top of that they're
select they're actually limited to words
that are in a particular word list
but let's let's just start off by
by limiting it to five characters first
and then we'll start we'll make use of
the word list after that
so let's see so we can take input dollar
guess and
let's say
um if
n sharp input dollar guess
is not equal to five
then
well we'll i'll show the this
sort of the
naive way of doing it first and then do
something a little bit more
sophisticated
and then
so if it's not five characters and we'll
just return out of this render text
function
for nothing or actually maybe we should
return the empty string
um and if it is five characters then we
move on and um
i'll have it uh
show this text so paste
you know
you entered
input dollar guess
all right reload
so i can say
adc and if i click on here nothing
should happen but if i say hello which
is five characters
it'll say you entered hello
and if i say goodbye
which is
seven characters long
um well it's not printing out you
entered goodbye but it is just making
the the result disappear
so that's actually not really what we
want either um
and
there is a function in shiny called rec
like for short for require
i mean you can use it to exit out of
here and
not
replace the previous
the previous contents of
of this output so we can say rec
false
and
okay actually normally if we just do rec
dot wreck false and we do this so if i
say
hello
goodbye
it will still like it'll still clear
this but what we need to say is rec
false
cancel output equals true
so cancel output means
um
when you
when you hit this line of code
um
don't
modify any downstream outputs that are
from this and this actually isn't an
output itself but if this were like in a
reactive expression that was consumed by
um
by an output then it would that output
would also not change so let's say hello
again and goodbye and when i click on
this
now it's it's not erasing the previous
contents of this render text
okay great
uh now we can compare it to i guess we
compare it to our word list so let's at
the top of this app let's say source
word list
okay and
um in this word list there's actually
two sets of words there's um
there's common words
which are there's like that's a list of
like 2500 words
um which are relatively common or the
more most common 2 500 words in in
english
and then there's a larger list of words
that are like all five letter words
um the shorter list is ones that are
um i guess the target words
and the longer list are is this is a set
of words that we can that users can use
to guess but but some of them are really
obscure and it would be really
really hard if those were the target
words
so oops let's source wordlist.r
and the let's see actually let's just
run that and
let's put that there
source word list out r okay we have
words common five and words all five so
those are
those are the two
character vectors that we have that have
between all the words
so
so right now
we
we just want to um
right now we just want to show
or
right now we just want to move on from
here
uh if it's if the word that they entered
is an actual word in the in the words
all list
so we can say if
input dollar guess
is in
words all
five actually sorry
take out this
parenthesis there if it's not in
towards all five then cancel output
okay so let's run it
and again hello should work
but and if we just type in some random
five characters
that should have no effect
okay so
that's pretty good now we can actually
start you know we can have make up a we
can use a target word
and
start
uh processing people's guesses for that
target word
uh let's see so
um we can do it well we can do it inside
the server function
if we do this if we select a random word
inside the server function that means
that each time somebody connects to this
they'll get a different word
um and if we
if we select a random word outside of
the server function
then
it will as long as this
app is running
and you don't like restart r or quit the
app or something or i mean close the app
from the r side
then um everyone will get the same word
so that's uh i mean let's do it that way
so there's words common five so we can
just say
target
is
sample
words common
five one i think that's the right
sample
yep just sample one of them so and
actually you know of course we can
always just run this at the console i've
got to stop the app first
yeah so that picks out one word duchy
that would be really hard
you know yet another thing you could do
is to like
set the random seed based on the date
um
you know i don't know you'd probably do
like as
ginger
you know sis dot date
okay so yeah
so let's
let's try this
and then
oops
oh i guess we can print it out so
for today the target word is gives and
then if we run this all again so like
let's say that the app you know shuts
down or let's if you're running you know
if you're running this on
if you're running this on a server where
there's high load and you want this to
be served up by multiple different r
processes
then you want this to be repeatable so
let's run this again and again if we run
target
it still gives
so so anybody who connects today would
have that word and i guess you know that
actually works let's
let's let's use that let's use that
method for now okay so um yeah so every
so today the target the word is gives
and we're just using that by uh setting
the random seed
using today's date
all right so
let's see here um
okay so now we want to compare we want
to do some sort of comparison to say hey
is the is the word that the person
entered
if they make it past this this part
there uh
like how well does that match up with
the target word
um and that's something where it sort of
it makes a lot of sense to put that in
its own function
and uh i will do that
i'll
i'll do that below the server function
so let's say
let's see what should we call this
check
word
function and then we'll say
uh the target word
and the guess
all right so
so what we want to say check is you know
not just are these two words the same if
that if it was that simple we won't need
to make a function for it but um in
wordle
we need to know like how many like
which of these letters is
in the guess is in the target word in
the correct location
and which of those letters
are in the target word and
you know not and not in the correct
location
so those are two things that we need to
what that we want this function
to figure out
and so we're we're actually going to
want this to return um
i guess it could be it could be a
character vector or a list
with like the status of each
each
uh
character in the in the guess so for
example if
so let's just let me just sketch this
out here so if you know the target is
um
gives that's today's target word
and
the guess is um
okay if the guess is i'll then
let's go through each of these letters
here so
what we want to tell the user or the
feedback that we want to give them is
that
a
is not the target word
i is in the target word and it's in it's
in the correct location
s is in the target word but it's in the
wrong location
um
right here
l is not in the target word and e is in
the target word but in the wrong
location
and um
and in
you know in
the real wordle game those are it shows
that with colors
um and for right now what we're going to
do here is we're just going to sort of
mark each letter from the guess and
we're going to we're going to return
some information about it
so let's see um
yeah so what we want to do is we want to
iterate over each letter
in the target
and guess
words and and do a comparison so first
thing to do
is to
uh
well should we do it this way yeah so
the first thing we can do is
uh
split those words
into a character vector of letters so if
i say
um
actually let me say let me change this
target
okay this is just going to be kind of a
long variant target string and guess
string
so we can say that the target this is
going to be a character vector
we'll say string split
stir split uh
target
string
and if i just give it a
an empty string here it'll split it
every character up
um
and so let's let's try this real quick
actually so
we can just do this in the console just
to try things out so if i say string
split
gives
on an empty string that will return this
well it actually returns a list
that contains a character vector with
the individual letters so what we want
to do then is
extract the first element to that list
so let's hit that again
and
now this is what we want we want a
character vector with those letters okay
all right and the same thing for the
guess so let's copy that
guess
yes
um and then and then after this now we
can we can iterate
over each of the letters
and compare them
so actually one more thing that we
should do ahead of time we need to make
sure we should make sure these these
words are the same length just in case
uh i mean
the logic in
uh that we had up above
uh should make sure that you know both
words are five letters but just in case
we want to
we should check it here
and and through an error if they're not
the same length so
uh
if n char
target
string string
is not equal to char
yes
let's say stop
target
and guess string must be the same length
okay
so
once we get down here we know they're
the same length and then we can iterate
over uh over each
over the words
all right so let's say for
and we can do this with uh we can do
this with a simple for loop there's
other things you can do like you could
use
and apply but in this case we can just
use a for loop so let's say for i
in
uh
seek a long
target
so that should be five that should be
one through five actually
we're going to do something
and
letter
so
let's say
if
guess
i
is equal to
target i
then we're going to do something and
let's see we need to
well if they're the same then that's we
need to sort of mark that and we need to
save that somewhere so let's uh let's
actually create another
a place to store this information so
we'll call this
result
and you can say character vector
uh
oh and actually and we can pre-allocate
this character vector uh you know
for this for these really small things
like performance isn't really a big
issue but
if you're working with larger data
then it it can help to pre-allocate
vectors so i'll just do that now even
though in practice for this it probably
doesn't actually matter but let's just
say n char
um guess string
okay so so again let's well if i just
we can run it over here in the console
and just see what that looks like so if
i say character five
it creates a character vector with five
empty strings in it um yeah so that that
lets us assign things into there without
growing the vector
uh in a loop and that because that can
lead to performance problems but again
it probably doesn't matter here
so let's see so if the guess and the
target
letters are the same for a particular
position then let's say result
i is um
let's call it correct
you can say else if so let's see if
there
yeah if the guess and the target are the
same that's good
um
that's correct but we also want to mark
if
the guest letter
is in the target word but in the wrong
in a different location so we can say if
guess bracket i
is in
target
then result
i
is um let's say
in
inward
okay and if it's not then
we'll say result i is
not inward
okay so we're just gonna
collect those results and return it
results
see there we go there's the end of our
function
so i'm gonna hit uh
just hit command enter to run this
and then we can test it out so let's say
check word
gives that's the target and i'll is our
guess
so let's go through these so the first
one
a is not
in the target
i is in the correct position
s is in the word
l is not in the target and e is in the
in the target so let's okay that's great
yeah just you know to me it just feels
like this is the right size like this
this is a function that just does
it's one thing it tells me
um
it tells me whether each letter is
correct and you know i can build on top
of that i can use that information
to uh
to see if
to check if everything is um
you know if the entire word is correct
so maybe actually maybe i should say
this is
this is compare words okay
and uh and then i can wrap i can use
another function that uses this
and then provides some even some more
information like whether or not the
guest was correct so
um
so let's say
let's make another
function called check words okay and say
it's going to actually take the same
inputs
but
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
return a data structure that has a lot
of useful information in it so
let's say actually do i want to do this
yeah okay let's let's do this okay
so
so i'm going to say
okay so compare
results
using some long variable names is
compare words of
these things
and then uh
let's see
if
let's say all
um
compare results equals if they're all
correct
then we know the um
that then then the person has has
finished the game there they've won
right
so uh
let's see
i'll call i'll say correct it's true so
let's start with
the default correct it's false actually
yeah let's do it this way
and then we can return a list
where the guess was
guest string this is the guest
word uh
the results for each
letter
is um
compare result
and
correct is correct okay so
um
we can
we can again do check words
gives and i'll
so
this is a list
the guess was aisle and
the result for each comparison is here
and this is not the correct word
but if we were to check gives against
gives
yep should be
gives us here the result for each letter
is here and correct is true
and actually i'm going to name this to
uh
oh
i don't know result yes
um okay never mind let's
actually i'm get here i'm going to
give another field called letters and
that's going to be
these letters
from the guests split up
because that may be useful later
okay
because i need a comma there
oh guess string
okay
all right so that's the
that's the word maybe i should call this
word
letters result
and it's correct okay
so um this this actually may be more
richer and this might be more and richer
information than we actually need later
but uh it doesn't hurt to
have that information now
okay so
we've written our function to compare
these words
and um let's see so we can say
you entered well actually let's
let's just take this
check
words
target
input
yes now this is going to return a list
and the render text is probably not
really going to like that
but what we can do is do render print
well actually let's let's first let's
see what happens when we do it
it's not going to
probably not going to be great so again
we know the word the target word just
gives
and we're guessing i'll
yeah so it's trying to it's it's render
text is expecting a string to be
returned
but we're returning a list with a bunch
of stuff in it so that's it doesn't like
that but what we can do instead is use
render print
and what render print will do is it'll
take this result as if you printed it at
the console like here and then it'll
it'll display all that information
oops gotta reload
so i'll
go
all right and
yep so this is the information that we
need and let's say gives that is the
correct word
correct correct correct correct okay
great
so now we now
you know
we're doing the sort of the proper
analysis on the on the word but now we
want to print it in a nicer way so i
think uh
so one thing one way we can do it is
um
for right now is we can print it out
with uh
like this and i'll demonstrate like
putting brackets in parentheses around
the letters so
if the target word or if the user has
entered i'll
um so a let's see let's say a
we can put if the letter is correct we
can put square brackets around it
um and if it's in the word but in the
wrong location it could parentheses
see in the l
is doesn't have anything and
e would also have parentheses so we can
we can print it out this way for now
um so the user has some information
about
which letters are correct all right so
let's do that and again this is uh we
could put it right in line here in this
render print
but
this is also this is also a good place
to you know to make a function to do the
formatting
so let's say um
say format
yes
yeah form a guess
um
so let's check words
results
or maybe format yeah format result
so these are not these are not great
function names uh
naming things is hard um
and you know when you're working on
something that's small
you can sort of get away with
with using just sort of moving quickly
and just picking a name and and
going on from there but when you're
working on like much working on bigger
projects
um
it's more important to have good names
because if you don't then you'll get
really confused but this is a small
enough thing that we can you can be a
little bit lazy about that
okay so um i'll just define the function
here format
result
function
this thing called result
um
actually let me call it
uh
well guess data is a little bit long but
um
g data
uh
or actually let's just call it r
so uh so we want to
for each letter here we want to look at
uh
correctness the results wow yeah our
dollar results again okay these are bad
names but
we can it's it's this is small enough
that we can hold it in our heads
so we'll just iterate over each uh
over these the letters and the results
here and you know put the proper
brackets or whatever around it
so um all right let's do a for loop
again for
i in
seek along
letters
and we know that letters and results are
the same length so um we don't have to
we don't have to do any checks there
so
um let's see so if
oh i'm sorry
oh that's right so if we could say if r
dollar results
i actually this should be our dollar
letters
okay
uh if our dollar result bracket i
is
correct
parenthesis there
then
okay let's make it
let's say let's call this out string
so
let's do
string
is
okay and we're going to do paste
zero
said square brackets
our dollar letters i
and then
close bracket
oh and actually we need to append that
to the uh
to the existing output string otherwise
we're going to overwrite it each time so
we actually need to do
a 0 out string and then stick the stuff
on the end
and you know once again i'm going to say
like this is not the fastest way to do
these things
if you're if you are
making a string by
just appending stuff to it it actually
in r it actually
will allocate new memory for uh it'll
copy the whole string to a new
location memory and then
put more
append stuff to it and that's not very
efficient but for this since we're
dealing with really small amounts of
data it's it's totally fine and it's
it's simple and it's fast enough
okay so
if it's correct we do that
else
if
let's copy and paste this uh if it's
what do we say
in word my else is messed up
okay if it's inward
then we'll do the same thing but we'll
put parentheses around it
and
else
well instead of parentheses or brackets
we'll just use spaces
okay and then at the end we'll return
upstream
okay so
here we have the results let's check
words okay when we want render text
not render print
reload
so i'll
wow that's perfect all right
and gives should be
[Music]
okay they're all correct there great
hello let's just try that one
great